wir brauchen auf jeden fall noch eine
leggins haben wir keine shit deathmatch
oder leggings bitte nicht bitten reisen
da geht bitte bitte bitte leise servus
skills und herzlich willkommen zu einem
neuen videospiel heute wieder jump
league und wir haben wir eine zuschauer
change am start und zwar stammt die
heute von so tourer zu tura ernennt die
die poker challenge und beschreibt sie
so wird es insgesamt nur fünf teams aus
den kisten nehmen das reicht genau für
eine rüstung und ein schwert vier
rüstungsteile bis ein schwert ist gleich
fünf musste genau überlegen was aus der
kiste nimmt es essen darf ich dazu so
viel mitnehmen wie du willst im
deathmatch darfst du aber auch nur essen
aus dem turm nehmen und sonst nichts
heißt leute
wir haben unlimited essen aber vom essen
abgesehen nur fünf teams in der ganzen
runde die ersten kisten nehmen dürfen
und das macht das ganze ding ziemlich
schwer ziemlich ziemlich schwer denn
einmal muss man ziemlich genau
kalkulieren um halbwegs ordentliches
equipment rauszubekommen also mit 82
stellen anfang nicht sagen okay gold
bugs die gefallen mir gut die nämlich
mal weil dann hat man auch nur die gold
bugs freuen wenn man später eisenguss
bekommen hat man probleme und wisst ihr
was um das alles zu besiegeln
schmeißen welchem ihr mann und seinen
ganzen stuff weg und sind jetzt komplett
auf uns allein gestellt
alles ist sie brauchen müssen jetzt in
den kisten finden wenn es nicht finden
habe ein problem gut hier ist noch ein
bisschen mehr mut ich nehme auch schon
mal die ketten habe mit die ketten
hobbys nie schlechte wahl die kann man
super zu reisen sachen tragen beim die
ladies da draußen können sich auch
bestätigen dass ketten oberhaupt da
immer sehr sehr attraktiv bei männern
sind ihr wisst ja es rege zu reisen was
darf man nur den kettenhemd tragen sonst
mit liegestützen fällig wenn ich eins
nicht gebrauchen kann dann sind auf
jeden fall liegestütze in deathmatch
denn die challenge wird sicher knackig
ok jetzt ist die frage kettenhemd nimmt
man sowas mit ist nicht schlecht aber
ich spekuliere darauf dass wir da hinten
irgendwo noch meine eisenstaedt finden
unter der bedingung macht es keinen sinn
jetzt schon das kettenhemd mitzunehmen
der natürlichkeit ein schlechter als
eisenberg auf meinte jayson verstand
weil die echt richtig cool ist fünf
teams in der gesamten runde food for
free aber danach nur fünf items
mitzunehmen dürfte ziemlich schwer
werden
okay hier ist ein stein schwert und hier
sind eisen boots steinig wird nämlich
mit
so wissen auf platz zwei okay wisst ihr
was leute ich spekuliere darauf dass wir
finnischen ich nehme diese nicht mit aus
der kiste so manche wenn sie jetzt
berater im ok warum hat sich die reise
mitgenommen
wie gesagt ich werde versuchen zu
finishen und die die akkus am ende
mitzunehmen und streng genommen bedeutet
dir boots am ende bekommen ja auch dass
man sich ein item genommen hat irgendwo
man könnte jetzt auch schicken sagen
es zählt nicht aber ich will nicht
schied nicht willst maximal schwer
machen deswegen sage ich wenn ich wenn
ich die boots am ende haben wir muss ich
mir noch einen slot frei lassen
deswegen hab ich mich mitgenommen gott
ich hoffe ich versetze mich dann nicht
bisher haben wir zwei von fünf erlaubten
mitgenommen drei dürfen wir noch
mitnehmen
okay hier ist eine eisen brustpanzer den
nehme ich mit
alles klar drei von fünf erlaubten haben
wir am start
und so weit sind wir endlich optimal
ausgestattet stein schwert passt in
eisen schwertkampf natürlich vergessen
weil maximal fünf items für eisenstadt
bräuchten wir selbst schon drei dann
könnten wir noch zwei rüstungsteile
mitnehmen wer glaube ich nicht so gut
gut dass hier ist auch ein ziemlich
schwieriges modul da kann man schon mal
ein fehler machen aber ich will
finnischen alle typ ist immer noch vor
mir er ist immer noch vorm ich muss habe
ich das gefühl mich jetzt richtig
konzentrieren hier sonst wird er einfach
durchziehen und finnischen sowie 280
papier soll ja leute sieht man mit dem
fehler gar nicht sagt marlene und der
hersteller was ok ich muss entweder aus
dem spind gerade auf ok er hat einfach
die blockiere nicht angezeigt dankeschön
so wir nehmen wir mal kurz raus
sprechen wir da oben sind können wieder
rein machen und jetzt hier so wir sind
beide wir wechseln gerade auf platz
zwischen platz eins und zwei da ich und
bei andere und ein drittes auch noch
dabei tricky so was haben wir hier nicht
gebrauchen kann ok zack und jetzt wird's
sehr tricky hier denn das ist ein
ziemlich schwieriger sprung können wir
es schaffen
oh ja ganz geschafft sehr gut module
zählen jetzt gas geben wir brauchen auf
jeden fall noch eine leggins haben wir
keine shit
deathmatch und leggings bitte nicht
bitten reisen da geht bitte bitte bitte
reisen leggins nein wir haben ein ganz
ganz dickes dickes fettes problem
wir müssen im deathmatch ohne leggins
kämpfen das war doch so toll fühlen da
die chain logistics da raus zu nehmen
die hätte ich mit rausnehmen sollen dann
hätte man wenigstens changer jetzt
gehabt man warum nehme ich dir auch
nicht mit wie ein halber rüstungs punkt
gewesen zu reisen lässt da kann man
drauf pfeifen
so jetzt haben wir hier immer 1 nummer 2
nummer drei nummer 44 55 weiteres
mitgenommen starten mit 51 punkten den
staff match mit dieser poker challenge
und das wird knackig aber wir wollen es
uns auch schön haben wenn wir sterben
deswegen machen wir die clique am medium
shader rein hier sagt komm jetzt denken
zu kraft als ob er uns weg klatscht
werden wir den shader reinpacken
du trägst gebietsleiter ja gut ich
anders gemacht so es ist jener vom
zickzack- gut der frist schon mal ganz
okay und unser größtes problem jetzt
leute ist dass wir nicht okay da macht
den aber gut büchern ist unser größtes
problem ist dass wir keine leggins
herausnehmen dürfen aus den kisten die
jetzt gespannt werden das ist unser
größtes problem denn sonst könnten wir
einfach ihr den typen jetzt hier
wegklatschen der zum beispiel eisen
leggins sogar wobei moment mal ich muss
noch mal den kommentar schon was sagt er
der sagt in deathmatch darf sie nur
essen aus den tour nehmen sonst nichts
sonst könnte man sagen okay wir haben
bisher nur vier items rausgenommen 1
steht uns dazu alles klar geht gewinnt
im alter was er für eine range hat kann
all das ist los mit dem motto rock
wissen auf meinem leben gott alter was
hat ihr sack für den range nicht normal
und 1000 besseres equipment
wir müssen erst mal laufen die müssen
wir müssen uns etwas überlegen
vielleicht abstauben irgendwann lotsen
abstauben irgendwie sowas herzliches
sehen was der typ in rain schattner okay
jetzt können wir die ersten beiden zwar
sinken
ja ok
bagdad durch die gegend wir haben ihn
wir haben ihn wir haben ihn in ein leben
verloren
wir haben selbst nur noch 18 das ist der
übelste nervenkitzel man da oben kämpfen
sind darum kämpfen will abstauben
natürlich abstoppen okay er hat
eingekehrt eine enge kiste daran daran
daran daran dass und abstauben abstoppen
der ist noch nicht völkerrechtlich
kataloge und das ist mir zu riskant ist
der eine mit dem opel und im op
da hinten steht er und noch ein anderer
mit drei leben vielleicht ein bisschen
rein hier vielleicht mache ich erstmal
ein bisschen abgang als ich muss auf
jeden fall guten turnaround land lehrt 7
rüstungs punkte hat eineinhalb punkte
mehr hat sich als ich muss auf jeden
fall mehr hits landen wenn man gleich
viele jetzt geben dann gehe ich da das
ist so sicher wie das amen in der kirche
dahinter kommt schon der nächste möchte
gerne abstauben so ok first ist bei uns
passiert ist bei uns so passt können wir
ihnen mit einem mit mehr das handwerk
legen und bitte komplett sich der
anderen abzustauben
wo ist der andere grosse frage ist er
hinter uns er ist direkt hinter uns
wieder sagt okay wir haben wir einige
kirchen eingekehrt alles gut wenn mir
rausgeworfen
jawohl 13 jetzt kommt er an er hatten
entspannte test ein schwert und drei
leben alles klar
das wird sehr schwer das wird schwer
aber wir geben ganz coole jetzt könnte
es reichen könnte reichen
alles das ipad2 tnt übertreibt minimal
witcher typ auf einem bogen oder auch
noch okay gut das heißt wir laufen erst
mal vielleicht denkt er und sein team t
hat uns wehgetan hat natürlich nicht sie
wird kaum schaden gemacht wo er 10 kurz
fest mein handy klingelt dankeschön
dafür
wir müssen wieder im kleinen turn around
geben
vielleicht runterhauen ja als ob wir uns
von oben den förster gibt es schwebt da
oben wir sind hier unten und der kilt
uns aber wenn man gut geschlagen leute
wir haben uns gut geschlagen changes
sehr schwer
probiert die auch gerne mal zu hause aus
wenn ihr weitere ideen habt gerne in die
kommentare damit bis zum nächsten mal am